[Applause]  this is the victory victor india charlie  tango oscar romeo yankee we're receiving  your signal request to know if you're in  distress  yes i'm in distress  standby  do you require assistance  yes i require assistance  [Applause]  is your vessel disabled  we are  [Music]  adrift  all right what is your position ma'am  there's a storm one mile south rising  swells send them to  ma'am  59 degrees nine minutes north  59 degrees nine minutes more 82 degrees  four minutes east 82 degrees  that's uh that's a ways out man out of  our normal range surprised we're picking  up that signal  it's a very strong signal  charting a course to you now help is on  the way how many souls on board  [Music]  [Applause]  we don't have any souls  you